hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
I'm sure by now that everyone has heard
of the dark web commonly known as the
epicenter of illegal online activity a
vast secret cyber underworld it's called
the dark web and people aren't using it
to buy shoes they're buying drugs
weapons anything you can imagine the
subterranean realm is sinister and
untraceable with consequences that can
be deadly people may also be familiar
with the Silk Road or at least its
history the online marketplace where you
could buy narcotics with absolute
anonymity but the dark web is part of
something much bigger the Deep Web which
makes up 90% of the entire web through
our internet searches in our daily lives
we only see a tip of the iceberg how did
this all start in this video we'll take
a look at both the Deep Web and the dark
web
for starters let's take a look at some
basics the web can be defined into three
categories first there's the surface web
and that's everything that's open and
available basically everything that can
be found is through a Google search
following this is the Deep Web this is
the portion of the Internet that's
hidden from conventional search engines
and it contains unindexed websites here
you can find personal information like
your payroll and medical records or a
corporation's private data and finally
there's the dark web
here sites are intentionally hidden from
search engines sites and the dark web
can only be accessed through special
browsers which you use masked IP
addresses to hide the identity of the
visitors so where did this dark web come
from in 1969 a couple of university
students sent the world's first
computers to compete a message it was
sent on ARPANET an early ancestor to the
Internet the concept of connecting
computers together was a radical idea at
the time and at certain motions the
progression to the modern Internet
but ever since there has been the
internet or any form of internet people
have used it for illegal online activity
in fact one of the first-ever
ecommerce transactions was a drug deal
in 1970 it was done between two students
at MIT and Stanford in the 1980s people
also attempted to create data havens in
small countries with relaxed laws these
early examples were nowhere near as
sophisticated as the modern dark web
however they illustrate the point that
they have always been people who wanted
to use the web to escape the eyes of the
authorities or everyone's eyes for that
matter
in the mid-1990s things started to get
interesting a technology called tor was
created tor stands for The Onion Router
and is a browser which allows users to
exchange information anonymously online
peer-to-peer networks like tor are the
backbone of the dark web for the dark
web to exist it needs anonymity tor
manages this by hiding the identity of
the user by bouncing the connection
through three different servers around
the world adding a layer of encryption
each time hence the name onion it would
be logical to assume that tall was
invented by a group of
anti-establishment coders and criminals
trying to evade government control
looking at the illegal activity of the
dark web this makes sense
however quiet paradoxically tor was
invented by the US Naval Research
Laboratory to allow intelligence
personnel to transfer information
securely another agency of the US
Department of Defense called DARPA
further developed all and in 2002 they
made it available to the public to this
very day
tor is still funded in part by the US
government but why would the US
government fund and allow the general
public to access tor well the idea was
to make it difficult for anyone to
decipher which information on the dark
web was created by intelligence officers
it's easier to remain anonymous in a sea
of anonymous users simply the more users
there are the better it's important to
note that without tor the darknet would
still exist tor is simply one dark web
browser to which there are many it's
kind of like if Google Chrome was shut
down tomorrow the internet would still
exist in 2014 dr. Gareth Owen provided a
breakdown of the sites on the dark web
by classification his research found
that drug marketplaces were by far the
most common type of site this was
followed by other marketplaces including
fraud sites and Bitcoin sites which are
mainly used for money laundering ok so
let's take a deeper dive and take an
interesting look at the deep and dark
web firstly it's huge and its size is
growing rapidly a 2001 study done by the
university of california discovered that
the dark web had 7.5 petabytes or 7500
gigabytes of information
in just two years this number increased
to over 91,000 petabytes today combined
the deep and dark web is over 96% of the
entire web to give you more of an idea
of the scale 60 of the largest deep web
sites collectively exceed the size of
the entire surface Internet by 40 times
when you do an internet search
you're only searching 0.03 percent of
the entire web the dark web is such a
nefarious place that you can get scams
based around murder in one case people
kept falling for an elaborate scam to
hire hitmen a website called Besser
mafia claim to offer the toughest
albanian hitman services but in reality
it was two Eastern European men tricking
people into handing over their money to
pay for hit jobs that actually didn't
happen after getting their initial
payment the fraudsters often strung
customers along lying to them and making
up stories about why the killing hadn't
happened yet they even started a fake
moral panic around the issue they
started up false campaign groups and
petitions calling for the beste Mafia
website to be shut down this is a
convoluted effort to make it look
legitimate it said that you can find
anything from an ak-47 to rocket
launcher on the dark web if you look
hard enough criminals have also been
discovered selling fake degrees
certifications and passports people have
also hired hackers to break into
university systems just to change their
grades stolen identities up for grabs
from the dark web passwords for
individual bank accounts cost around 160
dollars and your full identity about
$1,200 on the dark web there's also a
hidden Wikipedia this contains Wikipedia
articles that are immune from censorship
one of the most infamous sites on the
dark web is the marketplace Silk Road
the name comes from an ancient network
of trade routes which connected Europe
parts of Africa Asia and the Middle East
the name was borrowed by Ross Albrecht
in 2011 when he said of the first Silk
Road marketplace under the alias Dread
Pirate Roberts here many things can be
purchased with Bitcoin but mostly
illicit drugs and fraudulent
documentation such as passport being
mostly anonymous Bitcoin among other
crypto currencies was instrumental in
allowing Silk Road and any anonymous
marketplace to run Ross Ulbricht was
arrested in 2013 and charged in a
high-profile case with money-laundering
computer hacking conspiracy to traffic
narcotics and arranging hit men to
murder six people however he was not
prosecuted for the attempted murder
charges in October last year the FBI
swooped Ross Ulbricht was sitting at his
laptop in the science fiction section of
a San Francisco library but to ensure
they got the evidence they wanted the
federal agents had to grab Albrecht
before he had time to shut down his
computer my prosecutors in the case
essentially wanted him online and the
computer unencrypted at his arrest he
was sentenced to double life in prison
plus 40 years without parole in total
approximately a hundred and seventy
thousand bitcoins were seized by the US
government from Silk Road and ol bridges
personal account at the time this was
roughly a hundred million US dollars
you've sold at the peak of bitcoins
price in 2017 it would be worth
approximately 2.8 billion US dollars
Russ Oh bridge had a staunch libertarian
philosophy believing that he was doing
an ultimate good for the world his rules
for Silk Road outlined that only
products that do not cause harm to
innocent people may be listed he
fundamentally believed that he was
giving power to the people against the
government it could be argued that the
site reduced violence in society as Silk
Road provided a means to purchase
narcotics without the violent nature of
cartels gangs or local drug dealers Ross
Ulbricht is heavy prosecution has caused
a stir in the online community there
have been arguments about how much of
Silk Road was built by a bridge as he
had a limited programming knowledge some
claim that this was the work of a group
new versions of Silk Road and other drug
marketplaces keep reappearing perhaps as
long as there is demand there will
always be another form of Silk Road to
land the dark web have also been crucial
to whistleblowers The New York Times and
other news outlets have opened onion
sites to allow for people to anonymously
submit information so the dark web isn't
really a place to surf it's a place that
allows you to do specific things and
people should really know what they're
getting into before accessing it many
sites need invites and a lot of people
provide very specific services stumbling
upon a site by accident may even be a
criminal offense to make things clear
it's definitely recommended that you
don't mess with the dark web they've
been reports of people getting strange
phone calls after browsing through
forums people's webcams being hacked and
then being put on livestream for all to
see people being followed around in
public and being horrified to see photos
themselves while doing their daily
activities appear in their computer
later that day a lot of people regard
the dark web as an underworld an illegal
and dark place where criminals meet it's
true there is a lot of this type of
activity but the other argument is that
it gives people freedom it can stop
governments from overreaching their
boundaries it can keep people and their
ideas safe the question is how do we
stop the parts of the dark web that
shouldn't exist right now it seems like
an unanswerable question but people such
as tor staff are working on it in a time
where all of our information is on
and our identity follows us on every
post and search perhaps who needs
something like a dark web in order to
keep our freedom so I'll pass the
question off to you do you think we need
something like a dark web for privacy
reasons but on the other hand it just
might be the case in the future that
intelligence agencies compromised the
system without even telling us it's an
interesting debate if you're looking for
more and want to see another video on a
similar vein I've previously done a
video on the history of WikiLeaks so you
can check that out if you want oh yeah
and just before I go I was invited on a
podcast and a radio show to talk a
little bit about technology in regards
to my book I'll leave those links below
to if you want to listen so anyway
thanks for watching this has been - gogo
you've been watching cold fusion and
I'll see you again soon for the next
video cheers guys have a good one
if you thinking
[Music]
[Music]
you